la question est ce que vous y alliez
dans l'espace vous n'iriez pas mon
boulot
j'arrête et entraînement un quoi vous
emmèneriez quoi ça a l'air fun comme ça
ma mémoire on le fait à l'entraînement
ça va mais ça va on mange que
lyophilisée même pas je ne savais pas
qui va briller en quoi un mannequin
christian dior pour la sensation de
faire l'amour en pesanteur donc vous
aborderez un mannequin égouts ouais non
déjà un mannequin non mais moi oui ah
oui emmèneriez quoi vous naulleau on
essaie très sexy ce qui vient de dire
oui c'est moi qui avais dit un truc
comme ça
non mais vous emmerdez pas déjà de la
terre à la lune d'or ce bouquin de la
terre à la lune jules verne bien sûr
j'adore ce gars dame ne riez quoi bon
marianne2 vous qui avez des sales ont
duré dix heures et sur la tradition mais
non mais les allées
alors je le dis aux délégués sur la
toile est devenue champ
alors franchement je le dis aux
téléspectateurs benhaim est devenue
rouge à chaque fois que vous l'avez vous
frères elle en train de lire un bouquin
ça va tu l'appelles le jeu burkina a
sonné sur quoi le club des cinq
pour lui qui fut arrêté à l'habileté par
sa passion à l'habiter par sa connerie
avait pas vu ses nouveaux amis sur un
stade bernard werber et compagnie non
mais les mecs selva elle par cas des
gâteaux écrit des livres c'est suite au
terrible
moi j'ai écris pas si kulka tavannes h
me dire que c'est ma peine c'est bon
allez on y boit toi aujourd'hui jelly
mois marie bonjour vous à monique
territoire et vous avez raison en
apesanteur en plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
a été et c'est parce qu'elle est très
belle et très sympathique elle vole vous
amenez kelly vous amener clip personne
n'irait jamais rien à [ __ ] me faire ce
changement est arrivé dans l'émission il
était conçu les adore
et puis en plus il sait qu'à pas de
séances d'uv la base les bars venir il
va être blanc quand vous amenez quoi
vous moi j'amène gens me pour l'amitié
et mon mec pour l'amour pas mal mais
c'est qui ton mec quand j'avais besoin
de faire d'ici là bas non non et je
passais la sauvegarde ça va aller très
vite pour la stanley jean bizet sera
déjà à ben moi j'ai déjà dit oui c'est
vrai d'amour en faisant tapis c'est toi
et moi vous m'amenez pas ben vous vous
dites oui à vous y serez alors poussé
par la question
alors est ce que vous voulez faire
l'amour avec moi non ça n'est pas la
théorie non pas les traiter de la
question posé la vraie question alors
allons remplir nos valeurs
souhaitez-vous venir avec moi dans une
capsule sur la lune
2 juste tous les deux comme ça en
l'austro un peu denses mais non c'est
non merci oui vous alors elle part en
concert après la direccte les des stars
des années 80 ces stars 90 on aura avec
nous on aura beau jour
josée bouchard dans la classe vous
partez way est trop mais c'est plus jean
luc laramée bodjona lors de ce mois nous
poule
je crois une poule une poule pourquoi
une poule d'abord pour les oeufs ensuite
pour la compagnie de ce jeu compte ni
sur les mecs nus sur les copains nice
les coiffeuses avait savait parler pulu
par les poules bien sûr parler une poule
où y'a des choses km sur twitter selva
sur soigner quand même vachement bien à
tous et c'est bien parce que c'est quoi
elle fait mieux la poule d analyse
médias les gens comme toi pour combler
les prix parce que selon une analyse
c'est l'animal le plus idiot de des
animaux la poule d les mots là bas parce
que l'intelligent dont elle a besoin
pour faire buzzer
ce qui ne manque pas taxi que la poule
ne pompe pas dans l'espace ouais
exactement là on est spécial les
scientifiques 6000 hôtel où j'ai passé
elle aussi elle a changé
elle aussi elle a changé la loi 104
chimiste un truc
ils sont tous les deux alors là je
prends du crime passe autour tu vois je
prends du coin de sodium et je l'aimerai
la lumière tu vois qu'il noirci tête de
ma mère
oui castaldi des muette
la faillite à wenger non moi j'aimerais
ma femme parce qu'ils y sont mais
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais qu'à partir de maintenant on
l'appelait plus castaldi mais canard wc
ouais alors canard pc tu fais quoi
ma femme donc c'est pour ça qu'on est
content mais je sais pourquoi caignaert
[Applaudissements]
descoings quoi c'est bien vous mettre en
valeur sa tient pas oxis me très bien
bon vous amener quoi rappeler mois
canard wc parce que moi aussi j'avais
mon compagnon mais chez vous ça passe
mieux
dans la présente heures ça d'être
incroyable la répulsion l'apparition
dans les autres quoi mais la pénétration
dans l'espace se tenir très bons amis
[Rires]
vous êtes allé dans l'espace beaucoup
aimeraient chocolat je connais un petit
peu mais doit le connais l'espace mais
tout est une question de logique quant à
l'algérie
tu comprends tout j'ai beau c'est de la
grosse tête
ça y est le ba ba elle est passée à
capter la rime maintenant voyez ce qui
se passe à problèmes de chimie à
problèmes de match il a imaginé ce que
tu peux prendre dans l'espace que du
coup y'a pas de quoi cette incroyable
mais je vois pas en quoi les jours ça
finalement
bah oui non mais franchement pensé qu'à
ça des trolls ou à coudray va s'écraser
contre parme en face à un cinglé
[Applaudissements]
qu'ils regardent jamais battu l'as
mérité
oui mais moi j'ai pas besoin d'y aller
parce que vous m'avez vous allez payer
le voyage
à l'époque on faisait de la radio ser y
avait un mec qui avait sauté phoenix bon
ne vais sauter du haut de l'espace il
est arrivé le matin la radio me dis bah
ce matin tu vas faire un truc encore
plus vif que lui toi aussi tu vas aller
dans l'espace il avait mis une
combinaison bandé les yeux un casque et
où on était parti à tours effet j ça y
est je vais sauter de 300 mètres de la
tour eiffel il avait fait venir un
renault espace il m'a fait sauter de
joie
donc j'étais dans l'espoir en dur bah
voila mon dieu qu'est ce que vous feriez
vous vous aimez j'amènerai kouaman
l'espace franchement alors moi j'ai une
thèse à finir je mets déjà moi je vais
tout seul dans l'espace j'ai besoin
d'être tranquille qu'ils aient besoin de
voir ce qui se passe tous à franchir
pour troller voilà je vous le dis déjà
en tout cas fait une retraite une
retraite voilà bah vous pensez à la
pensée et à la retenue